And now it gives
me great pleasure
to welcome the 17th President
of MIT, Rafael Reif, who
will speak to us first, and then
introduce our keynote speaker.
[APPLAUSE]
[INAUDIBLE], let me
see if it works for me.
Good morning.
Good morning!
That was awesome!
Thank you, Lulu, for
your nice introduction.
And many thanks to everyone
who helped to bring us together
this morning, including our
host, the Committee on Race
and Diversity, the MLK Planning
Committee, and our Institute
Community and Equity
Officer, Ed Bertschinger.
And above all, a huge thank
you for our student speakers,
our incredible student
speakers, Itoro and Sergio.
You make us all so proud.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
This morning, this
morning we come together
to celebrate in the
spirit of Dr. King.
The value of activism,
especially student activism,
in driving social change.
So I begin by congratulating all
the winners of this year's MLK
Leadership Award.
I recognize that the
staff and faculty
who work on these issues play a
profound role in our community.
But in the context
of today's event,
I offer special recognition
to the student winners,
Rasheed Auguste of the
Black Student Union,
the Black Graduate Student
Association, George Chao,
an activist for graduate student
concerns, and Fossil Free MIT.
In terms of student
activism on our campus,
this has been quite a year--
an extraordinary year.
On topics from race,
inclusion, and social justice,
to climate change, our
students have in many ways
become our teachers.
That has been true on
campuses across the country.
But our students have
done things differently,
in a way that I
particularly admire.
I want to share just one
example, an image that I
will never forget.
I chair a group at MIT
called Academic Council--
it was referred to earlier
this morning-- about 30
of MIT's top academic and
administrative leaders.
We meet Tuesday mornings.
One Tuesday in January, for the
first time that I can remember,
a group of students were
invited and came to our meeting.
The leaders of the
BSU and the BGSA
presented their ideas for making
the MIT community more diverse,
and more welcoming for all.
Many of you know the students.
I'm telling you, they
were magnificent!
They were thoughtful.
They were creative, persistent,
specific, collaborative,
constructive, and serious.
They went out of their
way to incorporate
the views of students from
other underrepresented groups
as well.
And with Academic Council, they
set the tone of mutual respect,
and they earned tremendous
respect in return.
The students brought
their recommendations
to address issues specific
to MIT today-- improving
orientation, and adding booster
shots of inclusion education
after freshman year;
enhancing financial aid;
collecting and publishing new
types of data about the student
experience; hiring more
diverse mental health staff;
providing training to
overcome unconscious bias.
And the list goes on.
Today, these students
are collaborating
with Academic Council's
brand-new working group
on inclusion.
Together, they are addressing
these recommendations
and the problems
they aim to solve.
The working group will share
a public progress report
in time for spring break.
And I'm confident
that we are on a path
to sustained and
meaningful change.
You may find interesting to
know that Academic Council has
volunteered to be the pilot
group for unconscious bias
training.
For this exceptional
example of student activism,
of initiative and
constructive leadership,
I'd like to publicly say here
to them, thank you, and bravo.
[APPLAUSE]
As one of our student
leaders put it recently,
"It is wonderful to
see the gears of MIT
go to work on a problem,"
and I could not agree more.
One last observation--
when these students
spoke to Academic
Council, they made
it clear that some of
what needs to happen
has to do with human values.
They are asking
us to say out loud
that we value the
diversity of our community.
I do.
They are urging all of
us at MIT to maintain
a human perspective,
and to remind each other
that while the quality of our
students' work is important,
their mental and physical
health is most important.
I agree.
And finally, they are
making a powerful case
that a more welcoming,
more inclusive
MIT would be better for
absolutely everyone.
They are right.
And I look forward
to working with them
to make this vision real.
And now I'm honored to introduce
this morning's keynote speaker.
Freeman Hrabowski is
President of the University
of Maryland, Baltimore County.
He has held that
job for 24 years.
Now, I've been president here
for three and a half years!
[LAUGHTER]
I must tell you,
Freeman's record
will be tough, if not
impossible, to beat.
But I take comfort
in the knowledge
that he had a tremendous
head start over me.
He was born eight
days before me.
[LAUGHTER]
As many of you know, through
his leadership of UMBC,
Freeman has accomplished
something deeply important.
At MIT, some of the
work we admire most
comes at the intersection
of theory and practice--
when a powerful idea translates
into effective solutions
in the real world.
President Hrabowski has
become the leading theorist,
and the most accomplished
practitioner,
of the science of empowering
students of color and women
to succeed at the highest
levels in STEM fields.
UMBC's a predominantly
white institution.
By living up to his vision, it
has become a national leader
in the number of its
minority graduates
who go on to earn doctorates
in medicine, in the sciences,
and in engineering.
What's more, his
efforts have become
models for colleges
and universities
across the country.
For example, in
1988, Freeman helped
launch UMBC's widely recognized
Meyerhoff Scholars Program,
for young black men interested
in science and engineering.
The program provides each
scholar with academic support,
as well as personal
advising and mentoring,
year-round for the first
two years of college.
Their success rates
are through the roof.
And a very high
percentage of them
go on to graduate
school in STEM fields.
At MIT, we were so impressed,
that four years ago, we
adapted key features
of the Meyerhoff model
for a program we
call Interphase EDGE.
It serves about 70 MIT
undergraduates a year,
and the first Interphase Edge
cohort will graduate this June.
And we have Freeman to
thank for the model,
and for the inspiration.
Freeman has also
co-authored three books
on how to help young
people succeed,
and he has won a
great many honors.
In 2009, TIME Magazine named
him one of America's Best
College Presidents.
Three years later, they declared
him one of 100 Most Influential
People in the world.
And in 2012,
President Obama asked
him to chair the newly
created President's Advisory
Commission on Educational
Excellence for African
Americans.
Freeman's awards and
achievements are remarkable,
but I'd like to
mention just one more.
In 2015, US News &
World Report named
UMBC one of the most innovative
national universities.
MIT made that list, too.
In fact, our two institutions
came in third and fourth.
Never mind which one was which!
But, number one
was Arizona State.
Number two was Stanford.
So I'm planning to strike
a deal with Freeman
for us to stick together,
and earn the two
top spots next time!
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
In short, as our
diverse community
seeks a path that
combines the highest
level of intellectual
achievement
with a warm sense of welcome
and inclusion for all,
we could not ask for a
better guide and friend
than this morning's speaker.
Please welcome President
Freeman Hrabowski.
[APPLAUSE]
I enjoyed hearing that
we are the same age,
and that you were a number
three and we were number four.
You had about 100 years ahead
of us, you were founded in 1861.
And you have quite a bit
more in your endowment.
So I think pound for pound,
we're doing OK, also,
all right?
You get that, all right?
[APPLAUSE]
William Carlos
Williams once said
that it's difficult to
find news in portrait.
And yet men die
miserably every day,
because of a lack of
what is found there.
And so I begin with the
words of our beloved,
and now late, Maya
Angelou, who looked
into the eyes of this
country and said,
"Lift up your eyes upon
this day, breaking for you.
Give birth again to the dream.
Women, children, men--
take it, this dream,
into the palms of
your hands, molded
into the image of
your most public self,
sculpted into the shape
of your most private need.
Here on the pulse
of this new day,
you may have the grace
to look up and out
and into your sister's eyes,
and into your brother's face,
and say simply, very simply,
with hope, good morning."
Good morning to MIT.
Good morning.
Give her a hand for poetry!
[APPLAUSE]
I was so impressed by
the students today,
I got goosebumps.
And your theme is
truth and power--
I would have called
it truth to power,
as they both spoke so eloquently
about the challenges we face
in our society, the challenges
we face on our campuses,
whether it's MIT or UMBC.
The fact that we can
be better than we are,
and that students have
a very important role
to play in helping us look
in the mirror as a nation,
and a society.
As institutions give all
the students in the room
a round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
I was delighted to talk with
Rafael-- as a fellow president,
as somebody who cares
deeply about these issues,
and who was asking me
really wonderful questions
about my perceptions, about
my students who've come here.
I've got several
students here today--
if I have an alum,
who's here today,
who's here at MIT, or
somewhere at Harvard MIT,
there's several of you here.
Are you in the room?
Stand up if you are.
If you're in the room, stand
up and give them a round
of applause, wherever they are.
There's some of you here.
[APPLAUSE]
Very nice.
Very proud of them,
very proud of them,
getting rid of the finished
PhDs in the sciences,
and MD PhDs between
Harvard and the MIT.
And we've had a number of
students that come here
and to do well.
I dedicate this
talk to two people.
One is Robert Meyerhoff, who's
an actually a graduate of MIT,
all the way back to the '40s,
and a wonderful philanthropist
who worked with us from the
beginning of our program
to think about how
do we help more--
at the time, African
Americans in particular,
to succeed in science.
On a campus predominantly
white, when I first got there,
where students of
color, and particularly
there in that Baltimore
area, black kids
were not doing well in science.
And we started with young
black males at a time
when nobody wanted to
talk about males of color.
And it was Bob
Meyerhoff who said,
I'm already working on
some issues with my wife's
alma mater [INAUDIBLE] on women,
and I want to see-- he said,
because everything I see
on TV about black males,
if it's not sports, it's
about handcuffs, or guns.
And this was back
in the late '80s.
Give him a round of applause
for having that kind of vision.
[APPLAUSE]
And now we are proud to say
we have students of all races.
It's still heavily African
American and Hispanic,
but males and females.
And we lead the
country, not only
in reducing blacks who go
on to get PhDs in STEM,
among predominantly
white schools,
but for any type of
institution, we're
number one in producing blacks
are going to get M.D. PhDs.
Give us a big round
of applause for that.
[APPLAUSE]
And the other person
I want to mention
is another graduate
of your institution
at the undergrad
level, Janice Lumpkin.
The late Janice Lumpkin,
and it's hard for me
to talk about her, because
she graduated from here
in chemical engineering.
And she went to the
University of Pennsylvania,
became the second
African American woman
to get a PhD in
chemical engineering.
And she came to our campus,
and she was amazing.
And she helped us to develop
at my program in those years,
and supported it.
And it was the first time,
so many of my students
whether-- and I have
students from 150 countries--
it was the first
time most of them
had ever seen an African
American woman faculty member
in engineering of any kind.
You get my point?
So she began with
that ability to say,
it is possible to do it.
But then she brought to it
such compassion and brilliance,
and this ability to
pull people together,
and to say, we are better
than this, we can do this.
And she inspired so many of
the Meyerhoffs, but so many
of my white students to go
on to graduate students--
and particularly women.
She tragically
died in childbirth.
But she had just gotten tenure,
and we celebrate her legacy.
And I want you today,
to think about the idea
that this institution
produced both above Meyerhoff,
a wonderful philanthropist.
People say, well, was
Bob Meyerhoff black?
I said, black, his
name is Meyerhoff!
They said, well, your
name is Hrabowski!
A wonderful Jewish
philanthropist
who simply cared about people,
and other people's children,
and then a wonderful,
brilliant young woman
from Shaker Heights,
Ohio, from Cleveland,
who came here and had some
people who cared about her,
had some challenges, yes, but
who went on and got that PhD
and who knew the significance
of giving back to others.
And so, I want you to think
with me for the next few minutes
about the story of America,
about your story-- students,
faculty, staff members alumni--
each of us has a story.
If I were to give you
a theory, in this room,
you might be interested.
Most audiences would
not be interested.
In this room, you
might be interested.
And I will tell you that
if you look at my writings,
you'll see a theory of
social transformation,
saying that our
universities, predominately
white universities-- I wrote
it several years ago-- must
look in the mirror and rethink
the culture of the institution.
That is not just about
students changing.
I saw this on my
own campus, I still
see it as we work
on these challenges.
It is about the entire
institution changing, thinking
about its values, its
assumptions, the way it treats
people, empowering people.
That would be the
theory I would give you.
And we used it in
our-- I chaired--
I was the PI of
our advance program
when we talked about more
women faculty members.
We've used it with the
Meyerhoff scholars,
with our Center for Women
in IT, but more important,
for the entire institution
to say, all of us
must be involved in this work.
If we are to pull people in
who've not been historically
represented at the institution,
we must hear their voices,
we must think about who we
are, and who we want to become.
And my central point today,
as I tell you my own story,
is that the way we think
about ourselves, as a society,
as the Academy, as MIT, as
UMBC-- the language that we
use, the way we interact
with each other, the values
that we hold will shape
who we are not only today,
but in the future.
In other words, our
dreams and our values
really become who we are.
And so, I'm sitting in the
back of church, in the middle
of the week as a 12-year-old.
And I was always a little
nerdy kid, loving math.
I've always loved math.
I get goosebumps
still, doing math.
And I'm forced to be there,
because my parents say,
we want you to
hear this guy talk.
And they bribe me
with the two things
I love most-- eating, and math.
So I'm eating M&Ms-- the
good kind, with the peanuts,
and doing my math.
Now, I'm 12, but I'm about
to go to the 10th grade.
I've skipped grades, not
because I'm so smart,
but because I had wonderfully
educated parents who
had been working
with word problems
all my life, who had taught
me to study Dostoevsky when
I was in middle school, because
they knew the world wouldn't be
fair to a little colored child.
And that I had to
be twice as good,
and had to read broadly
and study a lot.
And my mama, who taught
math and English,
would work with my
father, and they'd
work with me to make
me ready, so that one
day when I had a chance to be in
class with white kids, one day,
I would not feel inferior.
And so I'm sitting in
the back of church,
and I'm getting fatter
and smarter all the time
as I'm doing this math.
You know, the Southerners--
Atlanta-- we like those cheeks.
You know that.
Got to have a little
padding, right?
And the guy says,
if the children
participate in this peaceful
protest, all of America
will understand that even
our babies, our children,
know the difference
between right and wrong.
And I look up,
because I'm thinking
about these hand-me-down
books that we
have to use our schools,
in our all-black schools.
And my parents are not
allowed to buy my books,
because then I'd be
different from other kids.
So you have to use
these raggedy books that
came from the white schools
when they finished using them
after years.
Awful for us, to
have to feel that we
were so second-class, that we
got their hand-me-down books.
And so I look up, and I
said, who is that guy?
And of course, his name
was Dr. Martin Luther King.
And I was absolutely
transformed,
because his message was this--
that the world of tomorrow
could be better than
the world of today.
And that I, a child,
could be empowered
to be a part of
that transformation.
That it wasn't just
about what he would do,
or what my parents would do--
he wanted me to be involved.
I go home, and I
say, I've got to go.
I've got to march in
this peaceful protest.
And my parents look at me
and say, absolutely not.
No, you cannot.
[LAUGHTER]
And I am so-- not upset,
not academically perturbed.
I am pissed, all right?
[LAUGHTER]
I am so upset.
And I look at them and I said,
you know, you guys made me go,
I did not want to go.
You told me to listen,
I actually did listen.
He tells me what
he wants me to do,
and now you tell
me I can't do it?
You are hypocrites!
At that time--
students, you did not
tell your parents they
were hypocrites, right?
Go to your room, boy!
And for that night, I
knew I was in trouble.
But the next morning,
they came in.
It was the first
time I'd ever seen
my parents looking-- you could
tell they had been crying.
And they said, it wasn't
that we did not trust you.
We know that if you go,
you will go to jail,
and we don't trust the people
in jail who will be over you.
But if you are
determined to do this,
and you've thought
about it, and they
said, why do you want to go?
And I started, I said,
these hand-me-down books.
I've got some good
teachers, but everybody says
the white schools are better.
And you tell me you
want me to get in.
We go through this argument,
and we talk about it.
And then they finally say, we
will put you in God's hands.
Now, if the situation
were reversed,
and my kid, who is
now grown, at 12--
I'm not sure I would
have allowed him to go.
You get my point?
It's scary!
And I was not a
courageous kid, students!
The only thing I'd ever attacked
in my life was a math problem.
All right?
If a fight broke
out, I was running
the other way, all right?
OK?
Not even ashamed to admit it.
But here's the point.
We did go, and I did
leave my little group,
because they were kids as
young as eight and nine and 10,
and while I was only 12,
I was a high school kid.
I was more mature.
And here's the point.
We learned in that five days
in jail, horrible experiences,
but we also learned that even
children can be empowered.
To know they can
make a difference.
And there is my message
to you, students.
That yes, you do have the
right, and the ability
to speak truth to power.
Give yourselves a hand again
for speaking truth to power.
[APPLAUSE]
And so, what does
that mean today?
What difference did it make?
Well, interestingly
enough, I wrote an article,
and it was so amazing
to me to realize
that most of the people
in this country today
were not born, Rafael, in 1963.
Watch this.
How many of you were not even
in the world in 1963, had not
been born?
That is disgusting.
I want you to know that.
[LAUGHTER]
I want to tell you to
get out, just get out.
[LAUGHTER]
It turns out, 2/3 of Americans
were born after 1963.
So the experience
that you hear me
talking about for most of you,
is like something in a book.
You getting my point.
And I am that connection
with those of my generation,
in about who was born
before that time?
Raise your hands if
you're older than that.
Thank you very much for
being in a room, all right?
I appreciate that.
You stay, all right?
But here's my point.
But within that period of the
'60s when people spoke truth
to power, people of all
races spoke truth to power,
we did see all kinds of changes.
For example, we went through
the Civil Rights Act,
and the Higher Education Act,
and the Voting Rights Act-- all
were passed in that
period, legislation.
And what difference did it make?
Let me tell you, that even
here in Boston, in the '60s,
we could not have had a
room looking like this.
You could not have had a woman
chancellor of MIT, Cynthia,
wherever she is--
you get my point?
For women, for
people of color, it
would not have been the case.
And the world is different.
When I ask Americans
the question,
what percent of Americans do you
think had a college education
when I went to jail in 1963?
What do you think?
Just spit it out.
Somebody say it.
What do you think?
What percent of Americans
completed college?
Ten percent.
This would be MIT knowing
that, wouldn't you, huh?
[LAUGHTER]
Absolutely right.
It was only 10%.
What percent of whites?
30.
7.
I'm hearing 30 and 7.
And you all are supposed
to know some math.
I have 10% for the whole group.
The majority of folks
were white, right?
Come on, math people
in the room, right?
It was only 11%!
And for blacks?
Don't be embarrassed to say it.
That's what Itoro told us.
He said, say the truth.
Say whatever it is, right?
Say it.
It was only 2% to 3%, right?
And we were not even
counting other groups then!
We were talking black
and white in the '60s.
In fact, watch this.
How many of you in this
room remember something
called black and white TV?
[LAUGHTER]
The older people.
And how many students here
have always had color TV?
That's disgusting, it really is.
[LAUGHTER]
Today though, we go to
all the different groups
in our society.
So, what percent have
a college degree today?
30.
It's just about 30%, 31%.
What percent of whites?
[INAUDIBLE]
It's up to about 37%.
What percent of Latinos
and Hispanics, the fastest
growing in our country?
It's just at 15%.
What percent of blacks?
It's about 20%.
What percent of Asians?
It's at 55%.
But there are certain
groups of Asian-Americans
where that's not the case.
It's very important when
talking about diversity,
to go to specificity.
There's a difference
between my black students
whose parents are
from the Islands,
and those whose parents
are from South Carolina,
or those who are from Nigeria.
There are differences in
the Hispanic population.
My kids who are from Puerto
Rico, who are from New York--
very different from
my kids who are
from the University
of Puerto Rico.
You get my point?
There are different challenges,
depending on where you're from.
But the point is, you
put it all together,
and we can tell you
that literally over 2/3
of Americans over 25 today
did not go to college,
have not graduated from college.
Why is that important?
Well, all of my friends, white,
black, Hispanic, whatever,
Asian, will say Native Americans
numbers are below everybody's.
You know that.
We've got to keep
working on that issue.
But here's the point.
All of my friends will say,
Freeman, that couldn't be true.
Everybody I know
went to college.
Duh.
Do you get it?
MIT professors know
MIT professors.
Grad students know
grad students, right?
Lawyers know lawyers,
doctors know doctors,
and plumbers, who make more
money than any of you all,
know plumbers, all right?
The point is that literally,
we've gone from 10%, to 30%,
and every group has gotten
better off as a result of that.
But here is the challenge.
The bottom quarter
of our country,
of the population
with every race,
the bottom quarter of the
students of every race
have a probability of graduating
from a four-year institution
that's under 10%.
I don't care whether you're
white, or black, or Hispanic,
or Asian.
Whatever the group,
right now, until we
do more in terms
of intervention,
to help with both the academic
skills-- in many cases,
the little children in Atlanta,
or in Baltimore, or here
in Boston.
In terms of the academic
skills on the one hand,
and then the issues
involving financial aid.
Because the financial
aid issue for poor people
is not that they can't get it
from the federal government,
it's that nobody's
helping them to fill out
the forms before the deadline.
If you don't fill out the
forms before the deadline,
you don't get the money.
And if the forms are
as complicated as they
are, like the IRS-- right?
So it's the financial issues,
it's the academic issue,
but it's also having
the dream, the vision.
And so here is what I
want you to think about.
On the one hand,
as your students
were saying, it is
so important that we
look at our own institutions,
in higher education,
to understand why students
of all backgrounds,
black students and others,
Hispanics and others,
are saying around
the country, there
are challenges on
these campuses.
We're not necessarily made
to feel like we belong here.
Or people are making all kinds
of statements and assumptions.
I'll never forget when I got
an A on the algebraic topology
test in grad school, and I'm
the only little black kid
in the class.
And the professor
writes on my paper,
you did surprisingly well.
Now remember, I told you, my
mother's an English teacher.
I go up and I say,
why the adverb?
[LAUGHTER]
He didn't know what
I was talking about.
I liked that, I liked that.
And when I pointed to the word,
surprisingly, all he could do
was turn red.
The advantage that
black people have is we
don't turn red, all right?
Got to put humor
into this stuff.
Tell the truth, but put
a little humor into it.
Ease it a little bit.
And amazingly, just
recently, that person
sent me the message
that in his own career,
as he retired, that I had
taught him the best lesson
about looking in the mirror.
And the assumptions
we make, if you've not
seen a little black kid
in a topology class, you
assume it can't happen.
When we said at UMBC
that we wanted students
not only to succeed, but to be
excelling, to be the very best.
And when we said, we want
to be able to place students
on the faculties of the best
institutions in the country,
that we wanted to
produce not just MDs,
but MD PhDs, we
wanted people to dare
to know, and to be at the
top, people said, impossible.
Impossible.
I'll never forget when I
went to one big foundation
and talked about
evaluating the program,
and I'll never
forget them saying,
Freeman, it's going
to take generations
before blacks will get PhDs.
And the person looked
at me and said,
you don't have the
gravitas yet in your race.
He said that to me!
And it was amazing!
I looked at him and he said,
now you're an exception,
but you don't have the gravitas.
You get my point?
People always want to make
the one person the exception.
Yeah, I went through
school early.
Yeah, I finished
my math major when
I was 18, because I'd had
advantages, and dared to know.
It wasn't about being smart.
It was about being blessed to
have people who kept working
on me and focusing on me.
Anybody in here, whether
you come from money or not,
and many of you
don't, but you had
somebody in your home,
somebody in the school, who
took interest in you,
and made the difference.
You are the most privileged
human beings in the world.
And at MIT, when I came
here years ago, Rafael,
with my dear friend,
Mark Ryden, and talked
20-some years ago
to all the chairs.
And we were talking
and he was saying,
these departments
represent the best
of their kind in the world.
And its inspiring.
But here is what I want
you to think about.
As you think about being the
most privileged-- all of you,
students, faculty
and staff-- we must
learn to look in the
mirror at ourselves.
For the students,
I would say you
should say what you're feeling,
what you're experiencing.
At the same time, know that
this experience is preparing you
for the next level.
Because the more
advantaged you are,
the more you'll continue to be
the only one wherever you go.
I have always walked in
and been the only one.
And people have always wondered,
is he really qualified.
After 25 years as president!
I still get that sometimes.
It is what happens, right?
Why am I telling you that.
Yes, we want to tell the truth.
But we need to decide,
who are we, as a student.
Who am I, as a professor, as
a president of MIT or UNBC.
And what difference can I make.
I would say to you, as the
most privileged in the world,
you have the capacity
to solve any problem.
You're solving some of the
greatest science and technology
problems that exist.
On my own campus, we
are working on STEM.
More than half my
students are in STEM.
Students from all
over the world,
and I see the intensity of
students from other countries.
I use that to get my students
from this country that get
that sense of that intensity.
If you look at the
Nobel laureates
throughout the 20th
century, so many of them
came, at the time
in the 20th century,
from European countries.
Their parents didn't speak
English well in New York.
They went to the poor-man's
Harvard, City College, Brooklyn
College-- Why did they do
so well from the humanities
to the sciences.
That hunger, that intensity--
We have a Chesapeake
Bay retriever
at our campus-- a dog.
And we have the statue of it.
He's our mascot.
And my basketball team
reads really well.
I want to tell you that.
Meaning they don't
win a lot of games.
But they read really
well, all right,
and we're great in debating
and great in chess--
we do really well.
Lacrosse does better,
soccer does well.
But we are a nerdy
place, all right.
And we've got 100
companies on campus
and what we are
always talking about
is, what makes the difference.
These are companies started
by my students and faculty.
What makes the difference.
It is that we call
ourselves the House of Grit.
The Chesapeake Bay retriever
is named a True Grit.
And we're making a
point to America,
stop talking about
this kid is smart
and that kid is not smart.
It's about how hard you work.
It's about having
support from people
to help you pull
you into the world.
What makes the difference
in the Meyerhoff program,
is that faculty on our campus--
most of whom are white,
most of whom are still white
men-- advances got me up
to 39% women
assistant professors,
though so give us a
big hand for that.
Big hand for that.
And we're just getting in
our first people of color
in these departments.
But the key is, that
my white guys get it.
If you look at my new
book, the publishers
wanted to know why aren't you
putting blacks on the cover.
I said no, because in science,
power is across races.
And white guys are
powerful, am I right?
My best friends, right.
So Mike Summers, he was the
investigator, my dear friend,
has produced more
African Americans
who have gone on to get
PhDs in biochemistry
than anybody in the country.
And so he is there with
the HIV virus, there.
People are thinking it's
HIV, because he studies that.
And what's amazing is I've
got a young black man there,
Meyerhoff.
Then I've got one of my mentees
who's a young Korean American.
All of them looking at
this disease and thinking,
this is a problem of humankind.
And therein is the dream.
That people of all
races, men and women,
come to know each
other well enough,
trust each other
well enough, work
hard enough, that
they work to solve
the problems of humankind.
Give the dream
round of applause.
The dream of solving the
problems of humankind.
[APPLAUSE]
And so, I want you to listen
to Marketplace from yesterday.
I was so pleased, it
just happened to come up.
They've got interviews of
my faculty in the morning
and the m and its on confronting
biases in faculty hiring.
And the significance to
the approach we're using
is while there are
people of color helping
in the training,
the real ambassadors
and trainers are all white.
Whites are the most highly
respected on my campus.
Who've agreed to come together
to work collaboratively
with faculty.
To help us to
diversify the faculty.
Give my campus a hand for
having the courage to do that.
[APPLAUSE]
It's on NPR, from
Marketplace from yesterday.
And so, I want you to
think about the students.
I want you to think
about the notion,
yes you want to think about
things on this campus.
But you also want to think
about things in this community
and back in your
own communities.
Because I cannot say it enough.
You are among the
most privileged.
And you want to deal with the
issues you as much as you can.
It takes time for
some things to happen.
But you need to support.
When you're having
a hard way, you
need to know and believe
that a sense of self
is most important.
You must build a community
around yourself of people,
and she said, of peers--
Itoro-- of peers,
of people who consider
you, it'll be OK.
And then you want to identify
faculty and staff who
will give you that support.
And you want to get into
those offices and say,
I need your help.
Never keep it to yourself.
If you've got problems,
tell somebody.
Say, I need this help.
Whether it's in a class
or it's about emotional
experiences that you're having.
And ask questions in the lab.
Ask questions in the classroom.
Ask questions in your
dorm, wherever you are.
It was I. Rabi,
the Nobel laureate,
who said, when he was
growing up in New York,
all of his friends'
parents-- mothers
particularly-- would say, what
did you learn in school today.
He said, but not
much Jewish mother.
He said, my Jewish
mother would say,
Izzy, did you ask a
good question today.
And the practice of
encouraging his curiosity
made him the thinker he became.
So I challenge you MIT,
to ask the good questions.
Not just about science
and technology,
but about humankind.
About the human condition.
What will it take to have
more diverse faculty.
If students are not
having the right
experiences, are we
listening their voices,
not just because they're
impressive as truth tellers,
but because we
want to figure out
the strategies with specificity
that could change environment.
Because students have been
asking questions on this campus
and all of our campuses
for at least 30, 40 years.
It's been a 50 year
experiment that we
have been working to pull
more people into this work.
And my final point
to you involves
the notion of struggle.
Anybody who loves math, or
science, or reading TS Eliot
understands that the most
fascinating work comes
when you have to dive into it.
I'm reading TS's The Wasteland
for 35 years to understand.
Every time I read it,
layers of understanding
coming from the
experiences I've had.
So my wife and I just
celebrated a big anniversary.
And we gave ourselves the gift
of going back to learn French.
And so--
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
Give me a big hand,
45 years of marriage.
45 years.
But I leave you with one
statement and one quote
from a poem.
It was Apollinaire, the poet.
And one of his poems that
says, "La joie venait tojours,
apres la peine." "La joie
venait tojours, apres la peine."
The joy comes
after the struggle.
All of this is about a struggle.
Anybody who's working to
learn anything substantive
is struggling.
Anybody's who's trying
to change at UNBC or MIT
is struggling because it is
not hard, it is not easy.
The Academy does not change
easily for any of us.
It takes effort.
1954, the schools
were desegregated.
In the '60s, I still
couldn't go to a school
that was integrated.
You get my point?
We have to keep working at it.
You know, in that last year
before Janice Lumpkin died,
when she died, I
asked her, what has
helped you to be the
woman of courage you are?
She was such a
powerful presence.
And she said, I
remember how blessed
I am to have had wonderful
parents, who gave me support.
I remember both the
professors who supported me,
and those who didn't
think I would make it.
Both inspired me.
She said, and I understood
that nothing takes the place
of hard work and attitude.
And I'm determined to help
my students understand
that of those to whom much
is given, much is required.
MIT, you do what we're doing.
You are supposed to be placing
the students of all races, men
and women, on the faculties
across this country.
You're supposed to be the place
the says, I'm a MIT graduate.
I believe.
You can do this, you have
the best brains in the world,
of every race here.
I challenge you
MIT, be the best.
Not just in STEM,
but for humankind.
Watch your thoughts,
they become your words.
Watch your words, they
become your actions.
Watch your actions,
they become your habits.
Watch your habits, they
become your character.
Watch your character,
it becomes your destiny.
Dreams.
And values.
Thank you all, very much.
[APPLAUSE]